-We're hanging out with the one
and only Drew Barrymore!
Drew --
Oh, lookit, I love it.
Come on. The greatest.
[ Rimshot ]
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Drew, we're a few months
into the new year,
and you told me that
your mantra for this year,
2022, is the Year of Know --
K-N-O-W.
-That's right, the Year of Know.
-The Year of Know.
What does this mean?
-Like Carson, Kreskin.
-Yeah.
Kreskin, yeah.
-Oh, the best.
-Yeah.
-Last year was
the Year of Less.
-You want less of things.
-Yes, I'm very maximalist,
gluttonous, live in extremes,
big personality --
nuts, you know, a little bit.
[ Laughter ]
And -- But a student of life,
always working on myself,
and every day,
I get a little bit better,
hopefully.
-Yeah.
-And so I thought,
"What if I took this year,
as, you know,
just trying to be really aware
of everything I'm learning?"
I feel like we're constantly --
I'm constantly one step forward,
a step back.
And I just thought
if I could have more confidence
in what I know.
And I don't know about you guys,
but my inner dialogue
is not kind,
and I would never speak or treat
anyone the way I treat myself.
And knowing that,
that's the Year of Know --
knowing things, recognizing it.
Even if you're
going on a date with someone,
we all kind of hard launch,
and, like,
"What is the future
going to bring?"
Just enjoy things.
Don't worry about the future
and the past.
Everyone says,
"Try to be present,
try to have balance."
I get so irritated
when they talk like that,
but maybe they're right, so...
-That that makes you
more irritated.
-Yes, which is even more
patronizing and annoying.
-Gosh, yeah.
-So I'm like,
"Instead of the year
of running around
like the crazy headless chicken,
what if I try to act
like this year
that everything I learn
is something I can truly keep,
and the knowledge is there,
and just have
a little more faith in myself?"
-Love this.
This is fantastic.
I love that you do that.
I mean, you --
[ Cheers and applause ]
The one thing -- another great
thing about the show is,
you really just put yourself
out there, and a good example,
I remember you had the cast
of "Queer Eye" come on...
-Oh, my God.
It changed my life.
-...and do a makeover for you
and had you do
an actual live date.
-Yes.
-And you filmed it,
and you showed
you going on a live Zoom date.
-Yeah, which I thought the idea
of a Zoom date was, like,
hell on Earth.
I don't know why, but --
I'm so IRL.
You know what I mean?
-In real life.
Yeah, you're so IRL.
-I'm so IRL that I was like,
"There's no way..."
-"I mean, totally be IRL!"
-"...I will like a Zoom date."
-"I know!
A 'Zuhm dut.'"
-I -- I -- I -- I tried it.
It turns out it's not as
prophylactic weird as it seems.
I guess we're all
sort of, kind of --
This is the new normal.
The water's out of the bottle.
It's not going back in.
It's dating apps and Zooms,
and maybe you can look at it
as a positive of a screener
or a time-saver.
I don't know.
I still want to meet someone
the old-fashioned way.
-Right?
-I want to --
You know,
I wrote, actually, a paper
that I'm gonna put on my blog
because I love writing
and I have a blog
and I've written books,
and sometimes
you just get inspired.
And I -- I walked up to a guy
in a park, and I was like,
"Are you single?"
[ Laughter ]
And...
-Did his brain explode
out of his head?
-And he was like, "Perhaps,"
and I said,
"Well, that's not 'no.'"
[ Laughter ]
-So...
-"I'll take 'perhaps.'"
-And then I was like,
"Are you gay?"
Because I also
always bark up the wrong tree.
[ Laughter ]
And he was like,
"No, I'm not."
And then we got to talking,
and we had such a good laugh
and such a lovely talk.
And then I was like,
"Ooh, I think I forgot
to ask you
a very important question.
How old are you?"
-Oh.
-And he was like, "28,"
and I was like, "Aah! Oh, no!"
[ Laughter ]
"Oh, no!"
-Oh, come on.
-And I was like,
"I don't mean this rudely.
You look so much older."
[ Laughter ]
And he was like,
"It's funny because it's a joke
amongst my friends.
They all -- We --
It's a joke in my life.
I look much older."
-Yeah.
-And I was like, "You do."
"We had a great afternoon.
Have a great life, bud."
-And I just said, "Okay.
That was so fun,
and thank you so much."
We had a great conversation.
And we didn't bother
with the obligatory, like,
"Let's exchange numbers,"
and I just said, "Great."
I said, "I got to tell you,
I just wanted to do something
that I could make
myself proud today,"
and he goes, "I'm proud of you."
[ Applause ]
And I was like, "Thanks."
-Fantastic.
"We got to hang out more."
-And we walked away, and it was
the most positive experience.
I want to do it again.
Was it dating apps
that stopped us
from going up to people
and asking them out?
Now we don't have to worry
about public rejection?
We can just hide behind the app?
Forget it. I'm over it.
I want to --
I want to talk to people IRL.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yes!
One at a time,
let's go through the audience.
Who want -- No.
[ Laughter ]
I wanted to see --
Speaking of
doing something again,
you did something on your show.
You do a thing called
"Drewth or Dare"
every now and then.
-At the end of every show.
Segment seven, on our way out.
-"Drewth or Dare."
-You did one...
-And I'll do anything.
-...and it made me laugh.
And it was --
Here was the dare -- try to eat
a lemon wedge and not react.
-Yeah.
-Now people have been doing this
online, it's on TikTok.
It is called the Lemon Challenge
or something.
Let's do it 'cause I want
to start a movement,
because I was shocked
to find out
how much I suck at this.
-All right,
so we'll just grab a wedge,
and we'll go for it.
This is the Lemon Challenge.
-And have you ever done it?
-Never.
-Okay.
-I'm gonna try to pretend
I'm fine.
-Okay, great, good.
-Like, big deal -- it's a lemon.
-Let's do this.
-Yeah, of course.
Cheers, bud.
Awesome.
-Cheers!
-Cheers.
Nice to see ya.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's just sour.
It's just so --
It was good
at the beginning part.
-And by the way,
these are good lemons.
This is a quality lemon here.
-It is a decent lemon
right there.
Just going for it.
Come on, that's a trooper.
Drew Barrymore, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Can you be cooler?
There's no cool like you.
-I can't believe nobody's
worn this sweatshirt
all this time.
No one rocks it like you.
I mean, look at the shoes,
everything.
You know how to do it.
Come on, bud.
-Pink shoe,
pink lip.
-The pink lip.
You know the deal.
I got to say, you know,
I watch your show
every single day.
I love it.
Congrats on that.
"The Drew Barrymore Show"
is awesome, and I --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you.
-I love it, I love --
There's so many things about it
I love, but it was your birthday
the other day. Happy belated.
-Thank you -- 2/22/22.
-Two two two two two two two.
-It's so crazy.
I --
I mean, like,
I was born in '75 --
1975.
-Yeah, of course.
-And you just don't even think
about that future date.
Like, it's --
it's almost a surreal thing.
-Yeah.
-Like the year 2000 seemed nuts.
Remember, we were all going
to party like it's 1999.
It just, you know --
-Yeah, Y2K, man.
-I never thought I'd get here,
and I've been looking so forward
to that auspicious number
of a day
that we'll kind of only see
once in our lifetime.
-But then you actually
were hosting your show
on your birthday?
-I was!
Which is so happy because I got
to wake up with the kids,
and then I got to go to work and
our job, our work environment --
you guys know it's a family.
It's positive.
It's like the rest of, you know,
your problems
kind of dissipate and fade away
when you go to work
because we're all working
on something so positive
and multifaceted
and that feed our souls.
And then I got to go home
after work, and I walked in,
and there was a blindfold
taped to the door and --
My daughters had put up there.
-Okay.
Thank you for clearing that up.
[ Laughter ]
-And I put it on, and I'm led in
by my daughters,
and Olive learned to play
"Happy Birthday"
for me on the piano.
She's in lessons,
[ Audience awws ]
but she taught herself
by herself.
-Come on.
-And then Frankie --
And they got me
a Fudgie the Whale cake.
-Carvel!
Fudgie the Whale's the best!
-It's the greatest!
-It's the greatest cake.
-And they made me
beaded necklaces.
And then our dog, Lucy --
And, you know, Gary and Lucy
are, like, twinning.
And -- And then
Lucy jumped on the cake
and started eating
the whole thing.
And dogs cannot have chocolate.
-Of course.
-So within a matter
of just a minute,
the whole place looked nuts.
-Chaos.
-And I was like, "This is
the best birthday ever."
-Yeah, of course, dude!
That's the best. Why not?
-That's it.
-I was watching your show
because I was like,
they were celebrating you
on your show,
and then you got a surprise
from The Go-Go's,
and they came on.
They Zoomed on together,
and they gave you this.
They made you an honorary Go-Go.
-I mean, that's me.
-That's Drew.
They -- They --
-I mean --
-They made this for me,
and because I went
and I inducted them
into the Rock & Roll
Hall of Fame.
Here's -- I have
a photo of that, by the way.
This is you doing --
This was genius.
You did this
as you were intro'ing them.
You started putting on,
you know, a night mask,
whatever,
a towel over your head.
It felt sort of like, "Okay.
These are the women that,
when they came into my life,
when I was about 6 years old,
they told me,
'You can do anything you want.
You can --'"
I mean, Nan and I made
"Charlie's Angels."
I don't think I would have dared
make a "Charlie's Angels"
if it wasn't for The Go-Go's.
And what I loved is,
they didn't say,
"You have to pretend
to be a man."
You get to be
with your girlfriends
and do everything you dream.
And it was the best sort of
tone-setter for my entire life.
So I was like, "How do I pay
these women in the right way?"
And I just thought,
"I'm gonna go back to
when I was a little girl,
saw that album cover,
and it changed my life forever,"
and I put the mask on.
-It was the best moment of the
Rock & Roll Hall of Fame.
-Oh, my God! Thank you!
I was so nervous.
-Questlove was there,
and I got a text from him,
he said, "Yo, your girl
is crushing it right now."
-I'm so relieved.
-And I was like, "What?
What is she doing?" He's like,
"Just wait till you see.
She's intro'ing The Go-Go's,
and it's brilliant."
-Oh, my God,
I felt so much pressure
to get that moment right.
How do you say to someone
or a group of people,
"My life changed
because of you"?
And the whole trajectory,
I know,
ties back to seeing these girls
that just --
There was
such a wow factor to me.
It was like The Go-Go's
and Pippi Longstocking
are my DNA.
[ Laughter ]
-Pippi Longstocking, of course.
-Of course.
Girls who were girls
who can do anything.
I told you already this,
but I loved your interview
with Donny Osmond.
I thought it was awesome.
I love Donny Osmond. I was like,
"Dude, it was great."
You were just great
and asked some great questions.
That's the part of your show
that I love the best
because you ask questions,
they're like...
A lot of the times,
they're like,
"That's the best question.
No one's ever asked me that."
-Well, thank you.
-And I love that you do that.
Yeah, I love it.
-I was freaked out
for your interview
with Dua last night.
-That was.
-That's my pal.
-That was a breakdown
of humanity and experience
and "These are the things
I've learned,
and this is how I've grown."
It was so informative.
-Dua Lipeeps.
-I already am, like,
psychotically obsessed with her,
and now I'm like,
"Oh, no. How --"
-She's actually cooler
than you even understand.
-It hurts.
-It actually hurts.
-But it was great to hear her
talk about real stuff.
-Yeah.
-You know?
That's what we want to do --
we want to have fun
and lean into comedy,
but I need to get real
every once in a while
because it's not all...
-That's why people love you.
-Oh, God.
-Yeah, because, no, it's good.
You get -- You get emotional.
You're not afraid
to do any of that stuff.
-I -- I know our tone
of the show is weird,
but I'm weird,
and I -- I like comedy.
It's medicine to me.
I like news.
I like, you know, food
and design and human interest
and conversations
and seeing somebody
you've loved your whole life
walk out and be like,
"Oh, my God," and someone
you had never met before,
but you will always remember
them after hearing their story.
Everybody has a story.
-Everyone's got a story.